j'ai pris un arrêté pour portant
interdiction de neiger sur le territoire
de la commune de cerdon
[Musique]
alala tracteur qui a trente ans de bons
et loyaux services alors en fait les
travaux vous voyez est pourri le
tracteur il ya des fuites partout mais
c'est le plus grave problème c'est que
le relevage arrière est cassé si on nous
dit il y en a pour dix ou quinze mille
euros pour le réparer c'est tout
simplement pas envisageable
[Musique]
les habitants étaient très mécontents et
je les comprends parfaitement parce que
moi aussi je vais ici moi aussi les
routes sont impraticables pour moi
également et je n'avais pas de courant
non plus les communes
au moins en moins de ressources
financières on a beaucoup de choses à
assumer face à ce constat donc j'ai
essayé avec humour de
d'alerter la population sur sur ma
situation qui est celle de tous les élus
locaux
[Musique]